[Music]
there's a giant section of aikido
training that tends to get overlooked
and forgotten about all the time and
that's weapons training site though
since I said that you cannot separate
the tae-jitsu and the book he was you
cannot separate the unarmed techniques
from the armed techniques if you try to
do that I could kind of makes no sense
so right now at a time when a lot of
different Aikido practitioners are
trying to figure out what I kid is about
my recommendation would be let's start
focusing on weapons when I start
focusing on weapons that's when a lot of
Aikido became very clear to me and the
tae-jitsu all of a sudden I could
understand how it worked so this little
video it's gonna kind of give you some
ideas maybe to work with the Aikido
weapons in a slightly different way than
maybe your previously been working with
them so an important thing to remember
is while the savuti are important to
know and the cut does and the kumicho
these are all important things
understand you can't hit something
successfully with the stick then you're
really training nothing so remember
every time your training weapons work
you're learning how to hit something
with this so if you don't have the
ability to do that you're really kind of
training nothing doesn't matter how
flashy or pretty you look or how many
things you memorize you don't know how
to hit something with this stick then
that's all useless so let's look at a
couple basic ski drills so thrusting
drills so I have Josh equipped here with
a focus mitt so we have these focus
mitts around for time move that way a
little bit and stick a glove out okay so
we have these these drills for we have
these folks myths for doing boxing
drills but they also work really good
with the Jo these are the leather I
don't know they weren't leather if I
would trust it but these hold up real
well for the Joe if you don't have focus
mitts you could draw circles on pieces
of paper stick them on a tree you can
set up all kinds of other things to
practice this with but when you're
learning to do this you need to be able
to target fairly well you're thrusting
practice so when I'm here like this what
I'm gonna do now is I'm going to go
ahead and do a sue bet ski and I try and
drive straight into that pad now every
time I'm doing that I'm looking
right at the center and driving in yeah
I don't right now I'm not working to hit
this as hard as humanly possible I'm
working to have a target and hit the
target every single time now he's going
to also use a hold these in different
configurations that's really high that's
maybe that's a head that's super high so
maybe chest this is a normal target here
for for practicing bang and so I'm gonna
come into that boom again right on
target every time low so maybe I have to
do a low thrust so we see this in the
third Kumi Joe and coming here low
strikes now when you're doing this first
you have to go very very slow because I
don't want to hit this guy's arm right
if I nail his arm that's bad for my
partner it's also bad for my targeting
so go as slow as you need to go
initially to get get the idea I would
start right at chest level exactly like
the normal target would be now as you
get better at this you can start
delivering harder and harder strikes so
eventually you're hitting pretty hard
remember there's two ways to thrust in
Aikido one of them is the sue bets key
and this is a tsuba this sliding action
followed by the delivery of the ski and
there's also just to drive forward and
put the Jo in so as they come forward
boom just driving that in you need to be
able to practice both of those because
both will be important in different
times this is basic targeting for a
scheme